the movie begins with a young man named
gao lying unconscious in a wrecked car
at the bottom of a cliff zhang a native
village girl stares at the car from a
distance a few moments later gao wakes
up and leaves the car stumbling across a
stony terrain he barely walks a few
meters away from the crash site before
zhing approaches and knocks him out with
a stone the scene shifts to eight hours
before the ghastly car accident gao who
is a gem hunter is joined by shauna his
dealer and ken his technician as the
trio stands on a sidewalk there gow
spots two sketchy men in a car closely
watching him from down the street and
immediately realizes that their hired
thugs gow bids shana and kin goodnight
before entering his car and driving off
as he anticipated the men also start up
their engine and closely tail him gao
hits the gas and speeds off prompting a
fierce car chase which causes the
accident back in the present gao wakes
up and finds himself in a primitive but
strange village here women are the
dominant gender as they hunt and provide
for their families while the men do
chores and take care of the kids fathers
are the home keepers and cook the meals
while the mothers serve as guards and
soldiers protecting their husbands the
village is a secluded area completely
cut off from the outside world as they
have no technology or knowledge of any
scientific products gao also learns that
sheng is the queen of the tribe and is
astonished to discover this initially
gow disbelieves her and assumes that the
villagers are just nerdy cosplayers with
great costumes and a perfect setup he
curses at shang and the rest of the
women which annoys the beautiful tribe
leader zhing is pissed at his attitude
and keeps gow in a wooden cage as
punishment later gao realizes that they
are indeed real people and decides to
return to the city as soon as possible
however yun-hee the tribe's astrologer
tells gao that he can't leave the
village without shing's permission after
a few hours gao begs shang to release
him from the cage and take him to his
car shang though skeptical decides to
have mercy on him and obliges the two
head back to the crash site as gao
searches his car for useful supplies gao
finds a metal bad in the trunk and
playfully swings it around mistakenly he
hits shing on the head causing her to
pass out on the floor gao seizes the
golden opportunity to escape and wears a
backpack as he runs into the nearby
woods a few minutes later the car's fuel
tank starts leaking and soon ching is
surrounded by a ring of blazing flames
the villagers spot the fire and quickly
rush to the scene as they pour buckets
of water to extinguish the flame gao
hears the villagers screaming from the
woods and feels guilty for leaving shing
behind he rushes to the scene and pours
a bucket of water on himself before
entering the fiery ring and carrying
shing out of it right as they leave the
site the car explodes and the duo lands
in a nearby pond much to the villager's
relief in the following scene gow is
back in the village and finds his phone
in his backpack he plays a song on it
which attracts xing's attention as she
rushes into the room sheng fears the
strange device and tries to smash it but
gow assures her that it is harmless he
offers her his earphones and the duo
listens to the music together as shing
falls asleep moments later gao lays a
sleeping shing in bed after which he
frantically searches the room hoping to
find a map that can lead him back to the
city in the room gowick statically finds
a sapphire gemstone and decides to ask
xing about it when she wakes up the next
morning sheng tells him that the
sapphire was a gift from her dead mother
a greedy gal offers her several items
such as a bowl of instant noodles a
novel and even his phone in exchange for
the stone however sheng refuses to part
with the gem explaining that it is her
most prized possession gao is
disappointed but resolves to steal the
gem instead later that day shing asks
gao to meet her in an open field at
night so they can watch the stars
together gao accepts the offer as shing
sheepishly smiles and leaves his shed
that night the duo lay on the grass and
stare at the starry sky suddenly shink
pounces on gao and tries to remove his
clothes much to his surprise he throws
her off and the two get into a heated
argument gao is shocked to discover that
in the village to watch the stars means
to have sex hence why sheng pounced on
him suddenly gao sprints to the village
to escape with shing in hot pursuit xing
is angry at gao and imprisons him when
they return to the village gao explains
to shing that he didn't know the
phrase's hidden meaning and took it at
face value he also states that where he
comes from people express their feelings
romantically like confessing their love
when it snows shang finally understands
gao but still has him spend the night in
the cell while she returns to her shed
back in the city shauna and ken
earnestly search for gao to no avail
they check the road where his car
swerved off the cliff but are
disappointed to find nothing kin uses a
drone to search the area but a magnetic
field disrupts the aircraft and causes
kin's monitor to go blank when the duo
return home they meet lee anne a
businesswoman with whom gao signed a
contract the contract mandates gao to
meet with leanne every 15 days and
failure to do so attracts a 60 million
fine so far it has been 13 days since
his disappearance so leanne has come to
find him shauna lies that gao took a
trip to the mountains and will be back
soon lyan is unconvinced but gives the
duo 48 hours to find gao before she
takes action back in the village shing
takes gao to the woods shane confesses
her love for him and asks him to marry
her as she dumps a bucket of chicken
blood on him apparently shane misheard
him last night and thought he said blood
instead of snow as both words sound
similar in chinese gow is pissed at her
and walks away in frustration but is
caught in a trap shortly after gao
desperately begs shang to free him from
the trap however shing asks him to
accept her wedding proposal before she
does this and a defeated gal ultimately
agrees on their way back gao finds one
of the blades of kin's drone lying in
the bushes seeing this he registers that
his friends are looking for him and
decides to escape from the village as
soon as possible that night gao and
shang converse and decide to get married
the next day gao asks xing about the
village's terrain and learns that
there's a secret cave in the forest he
figures that the cave is an exit from
the village and plots to use it to
escape gao also learns that the village
has a wine reserve and begs sheng to
take him to it she obliges and the duo
heads to the village's central pantry
without her knowledge gow drops some
sleeping pills into the wine barrel as a
ploy to knock out all the villagers
during their wedding later the couple
returns to gow's room and shing offers
him her sapphire stone as an early
wedding gift gao feels guilty but
collects the gem anyway the following
night the couple has their wedding
ceremony and observes the tribe's unique
rights as shin goes down on one knee and
confesses her love for gao gao accepts
her to be his wife after which the
villagers sing and play a love song as
the newlyweds dance in unison to end the
feast gao proposes a toast and urges the
villagers to drink their respective
bowls of wine the unsuspecting natives
swallow the drug to drink but gao tosses
his away when no one is watching a few
hours later the villagers all fall
asleep while gao packs a bag and leaves
the village he goes through the woods
and eventually reaches the cave which
connects to the outside world determined
gao enters the dark cave and begins his
journey to the city the next morning he
finally reaches the end of the cave and
races to the top of a mountain smiling
as he sees a nearby road back at gao's
house leanne arrives with her man as the
48-hour deadline is almost over leanne
asks shauna and ken about gao's
whereabouts but the duo reveals that
they have no idea where he is hearing
this leanne offers shauna a contract
that would transfer ownership of the
house to her shauna refuses to sign the
paperwork but leanne gives her no choice
the woman signals her men to hold the
duo hostage as shanna is forced to sign
the paper with a thumb print fortunately
gao barges through the front door right
in time to stop them kin takes advantage
of the distraction and swallows the
signed contract while gao speaks to
leanne ultimately the businesswoman
leaves the house and promises to keep in
touch when she leaves gal freshens up
and shares a meal with his friends who
ask where he's been this entire time gao
wants to protect the villagers from the
outside world so he tactfully avoids
their questions and lies to his friends
after their meal gow shows them the
sapphire gem he got from shang the duo
marvels at the stone in disbelief as
they haven't seen a sapphire of that
size in years finally gao hands the gem
to shauna alongside a soil sample from
the village for testing later that day
the trio visits gao's uncle when at a
nursing home and puts on a clown costume
to entertain the elderly occupants that
doesn't look entertaining that looks
scary as hell in the following scene the
villagers wake up and frantically search
the area for gao shing is heartbroken by
his disappearance and soon after figures
that he escaped along with the gem
overcome with sadness she decides to go
to the city to search for him the
villager's astrologer yun-hee initially
disproves of her heading to the city
however when sheng begs her yoon hee
takes shang to the cave's entrance and
warns her to be careful of the city
people before the queen departs when
sheng arrives at the city she runs into
yi tian a famous astrology social media
influencer who is searching for a female
co-host xing's strange attire and quirky
behavior pique his interest and he
offers to sign her to his company yee
asks for her manager but a confused
shing merely hands him a card that gao
left behind in the village yee finds a
number on it and traces gao to a nearby
nursing home at xing's request yi drives
her to the revealed location to look for
gao when they arrive at the nursery gao
spots sheng from a distance and runs
before she sees him he hides behind some
bushes and observes shang as she
searches for him ching eventually gives
up and walks towards the home's exit but
immediately turns around when she hears
gao sneeze from a nearby bush gao pops
out with his clown costume but shing
doesn't recognize him and merely watches
as he jumps away sneezing bushes and
clowns the modern world must seem
bananas to shang moments later sheng
joins yi in the car and the duo drives
away from the home while conversing yi
tells an ignorant shang that clowns
aren't real creatures but are mere
humans wearing masks shang is astonished
by the revelation and figures that the
strange clown she saw at the home was
indeed gao she begs yi to return her to
the nursery and the media influencer
obliges sadly when they reach the
nursery gao and his friends are long
gone and sheng is left disappointed once
again yee volunteers to take shang to
his house but the tribe leader refuses
and sits on a pavement in front of the
nursery declaring that she'll wait for
gao to return ye he desperately tries to
get her to leave but she refuses and
even remains seated under the pouring
rain meanwhile gao feels guilty for
hiding from shing and gets kin to find
her location a few minutes later ken
informs him that xing together with ye
is still at the nursing home gao thanks
kin for his help and immediately drives
back to the nursery there gao spots
shing sitting in the rain with yi beside
her he pulls up in front of the duo and
winds down his window sheng is shocked
to see him and immediately grabs him by
his shirt gao frantically begs her not
to punch him and comes up with an absurd
lie stating that it is wrong to hit
people in the rain shing is naive so she
believes him and enters his car as he
drives her back to his house immediately
after they arrive shing points her
crossbow at him but gao manages to calm
her down and puts the weapon down shang
asks gao to return her sapphire however
the cunning gem hunter distracts her by
offering a cake sheng tries the sugary
treat and forgets about the stone as she
viciously munches on it savoring its
foreign taste when she's done with her
meal shing spends the rest of the day
exploring the house as she adapts to the
new environment she shoots an arrow at
the television set thinking it to be a
monster but gao explains that it's
simply a gadget that can't hurt her xing
is fascinated by the modern world and
celebrates as she swings a punctured
feather pillow making a mess of his
house the following day shauna visits
gao and is shocked to find the living
room in a mess shortly after shing
approaches her while eating a bowl of
instant noodles shauna snatches the dish
from shang and demands to know who she
is and what her relationship is with gao
shing is pissed off by shana's attitude
and grabs her by the face as the dealer
screams in fear gow is woken up by the
scream and rushes downstairs to find out
what happened he finds shauna wrapped in
a blanket with a cloth over her mouth
gao quickly frees her and is horrified
to learn that shing is responsible
shanna is furious and asks him who the
strange-looking girl was immediately gao
grabs shauna and takes her to his room
upstairs then he comes clean and reveals
what happened when he went missing gao
explains that xing is the queen of a
secluded matriarchal village where women
rule and men are submissive shauna
initially disbelieves him but realizes
he's telling the truth when gao shows
her shing's native crossbow in the
living room shing hears a knock on the
window and is shocked to find ye outside
the house she rushes to the door and
tries to open it but can't figure out
how with yi's direction shing finds the
door handle but uses brute force to turn
it thus breaking it eventually she gives
up trying to open the door and breaks it
entirely gao and shauna hear the sound
of the crashing door and rush downstairs
to find what happened gao is livid to
find ye in his home and drags him out
before locking his gate however ye
refuses to leave and reveals that he
knows shing is from a secluded island
gao is shocked to hear this and
threatens yi to stay away from her as he
heads back to the house with shing the
following day gao takes sheng to a
fashion store to get some new clothes
sheng tries on some outfits while gao
steps out to give her some privacy
outside gao is astonished to see lee
anne approaching from a distance and is
scared to have her discover shang hence
he immediately hides behind a wall and
closely watches as the stern woman
enters the store to see what happens
next watch the second part in series
recap